今日はこちらスピーカー分です
また言葉の勉強についての話ですけれども
今日はねーものを探すことという言葉の勉強のくっけ
bea
うん
分
それじゃあものを探すことと言葉が勉強とどういう関係があるのかと
多分
皆さんかを考えていると思うんですが実はですねあの
今言葉の勉強が非常にや類やすくなっているわけですよ
僕は毎日その ipad でですね
リンクを使ってアラームボート停車語を勉強しています
で例えばランニングするときにこの
ipod 使って木々な部屋走ります
ipad 誓う時にですね
この際はそ使うんですよ以上に僕もちょっとてがあまり
熊谷ことできませんからスタイラスの方がやりやすいんですよ
それで聴くときにですねアパート使えますそれがやはりそういうその言葉の勉強の周り
のそういう
環境というかそういういろんな技術が非常にそのまあ
言葉の勉強そのものがもうやりは安くなってるけれども非常に残念なのはですね
こういうちっちゃいものが枚となってはもう少し大きいけれどももう
あいぽんも含めてですね
前によってメガネもですね
作者方
行方不明になるんですよ
1問その探さないというのはどこに置いたかと
この l判にしてもスターやすいしてもメガネにしてまだ目ではこういうふうにして
ますからまだいいんですけれども
starless もですね3つ4つぐらい待ってますからなくなってもまた違った
あの箱
starless 使うんですけれどもやはりえーるプロセスそんなパクさあ持ってる
わけ
じゃあ行きませんので高いですからその air の ipod それんですよ
探すときにですね
不思議なのはですね
北畝ラストには探せないですよ見当たらないんです
ワイフは探すとです眠いはず探し出すんですよ見えたんですよ
なぜですか
僕はあの自信ないんですよ偏見を持っています
例えば
じゃあ自分でその部屋でですねこのこのズボンは昨日
切ってなかったらそこにいないはずなんですよ
だからまぁちょっとだけ探したら触ったらやいないとあるいはこの部屋に機能をい
なかったとか昨日はこの車使わなかったとか
所有所の多分ないだろうと
いう偏見を持ってですねそして僕のそういう偏見
ないだろうという偏見の通り見当たらないんですよ見つからないんですよ
ただはイファそうじゃないですわぁファーすべてローズフォームを探すわけでしょ
黒星上がるんですよ偏見じゃないから別に多分ないだろうと
いう変形がないわけですよそれで彼女は探し出す
でそれはじゃあことの言葉の勉強に対してどういう関係があるのかというとやはり僕は
佐賀市と小城ば下手ですよ
第か意味分からないんです弱いに依存していますけれども助かりますけれども言葉の
勉強の時はですねいくら時間経っても
続けて聞きながら読みながら
機会があれば使えば必ず必ず火街道も良くなる
言葉を使うことになります
続ければもう最後まで続ければもう完全にビュー所に話せるようになりますと非常に
自信あるんですよ
なぜ自信あるかというと
それは僕は何回も何回もやったことありますから
最初のいわゆる
あの代二だいじ各国その外国語を勉強するときに気分が者流暢に
他の言葉を使えるようになるかって言うとその
やったことのない人にはですねそういう自信がない
それは私がいろんなものを探すときと同じ多分ないだろう
じゃないだろうというのはないんですよ見当たらないんですよ
で自分が者流暢に話せるようになる慈悲がないと多分
ビュー長に話せないことになり
ますだから自分を信じて
所有経営それが23回も行った経験があれば
者 gc がチクリとしかしどうやってじゃあ
初めてその外国語を勉強するときにかなり流暢になる
そういう経費がないとその自信はどこから来るんですか
それはやはりそれだけ信じ
ka その立証できなくてもですね
自分ねそのそういうことの経験がないにしても信じて他の人もそれができるわけです
けどできたわけですから私もできますよと
だから続ければ必ずそうなるとその辺の地震
いう偏見自分ができないという偏見で者ばやはり
吹い意識的にですねそのたくさんの人を持ってるわけですよ多分無理だろう
私はそういうあの才能がないだろうとそういうその
あるですよフリプ意識的なですね
あの変形があるそれややめて
必ず
やっぱり探し出すだろうと
で守備でのところ
母のざらすから
変形になしそれと同じようにあの言葉の
そういう勉強ができますと自信を持って続けて
いくら真保火事てないと
いつまで経っても良くならないとだけでも実際にはローが十分な悲劇あれば自由文に
ですね
聞いたり読んだり使ったり続ければ必ず覚えられる
それは脳の機能ですからそういうを信じて所属するものさ
明日ときにやはりんん
かなり
あげていいいい
あれですよあの飛来してますけれども皆さん自分の
みやたんないものも
探し出してください
まあそういうことで
いいいい
うん
うんいいいいいい
入った